men want and the fact that you think you
can sit there and tell men what they
should actually want without actually
asking them what they actually want is
the problem okay i'll tell you how i
know this do you know what women want oh
we know what we want we've been we we've
been told we've been told what women
right you want somebody who can
be a good father
right
um you want someone to support your
dreams if you have them right
you want somebody who listens you want a
man who
like we've heard all of this you know as
men like we've heard it for like
listen we've heard it for decades
we need you
let me let me let me ask you guys what
do you think men want oh give me three
husbands because i just i just named
five okay
four out of five men want uh somebody
that can be a support system without
judgment that means that when you come
home and you're having your man problems
you can actually come to somebody and be
that person that lays down and shows
some sort of vulnerability without being
judged because the man is a man bullet
point them bullet point one that's one
you want you want somebody that can be
caring be listening to without judgment
you want somebody you can trust okay two
you want somebody that is nurturing
because that person is going to be your
wife is going to be the mother of your
children and your offspring obviously
they have to succeed in life and you
ideally so you want somebody that can
nurture that and create a home out of a
house and then third you probably want
someone that can actually satisfy not
probably definitely that one that
satisfies your needs sexually no no
listen wait where is the submission part
though wait i was waiting
the submission comes from the part that
where the woman is supportive submission
doesn't actually mean the new one has to
be below a man a woman needs to be
supportive or he's wrong yeah you know
the same way a man needs to be
supportive you don't know what people no
no no no you you actually don't know
what matters right well i think if
that's not what men want there's the
same way that women want certain things
there's nothing there's three guys here
men then should be considered as well
what they think women want because the
problem is that people don't feel i
don't feel like people understand what
the what a partnership or unionship
means between a man and a woman there's
a lack of understanding of what you're
actually meant to be doing together so
when i name those four or five things
was i generally right yeah kind of but
not really when you just i don't know
when you just went on your rant do you
think you were generally right yes no
you weren't
sure
this is true and this is the problem no
because okay so you don't you want a
woman that you come home and say you
know baby okay so the problem so the
problem is you you think you do
the problem the problem is you speak a
lot but you don't listen that's the
problem and so when men speak and this
and this has been the problem for like a
long time
when men start speaking and telling you
exactly what they want women find
excuses as to not give the men
what they're actually asking for okay so
when men start saying what they want
women start saying oh that's
misogynistic
oh that is um that that's patriarchy all
of these things that's what women start
saying but men have been
the same from
day one men have generally not changed
friendly fit feminine friendly it goes
to your point about submissiveness so if
you say that women react in that sort of
way if they don't and they just say yeah
okay i'm understanding what you want
then that's the submissiveness that you
are talking about isn't it really rather
than being yeah because directly you're
right you're right because it's
agreeable so like disagreeable as a
masculine masculine is like for example
this woman i heard about some some
random [ __ ] here saying he's like
they're married here and the woman is
like
ah i don't want to have sex every day
this that this it's my body [ __ ] up man
when you're when you're getting a
marriage
you are my [ __ ] so when you're on my
if i want to have sex if i came home
from a long day trying to provide for
you you're going to open i'm going to
get yeah but you get smashing like what
the hell
that's lack of respect that a woman
actually wants
do not think that sex is dude
okay do you think sex is a duty in
marriage no that's why i said they want
the woman to satisfy his sexual pleasure
okay okay so okay so no no yes what
about yeah yeah yes because i i would
say like if he's marrying you he's
protecting and providing why would you
not give him sex no i'm not saying like
we're not i'm not giving him sex it's
just like he shouldn't be a duty he
shouldn't be like okay if you don't if
you don't give it to you but you can't
force me
on ownership but see that that's like a
lack of submission though because if
you're submissive you just say okay yeah
whenever you want because you're you're
the man you're in charge like i also
finished work or everything like that
and he wants to have um
you know okay do you do do you show up
to your job when you don't feel like it
sorry do you show up to your job when
you don't feel like it yes being a wife
is a job that's your job just do it
because even when you don't feel like it
so may i ask a question then you're a
man your provider i want this so you go
get it for me because you're a man you
know what a woman wants provide that for
me and that's it providing work the
moment you provide me what i want i want
a bigger house i want a bigger car i
want a bigger boat wait wait wait i'm
actually exactly but you're a provider
and when you're married you are my man
provide for
no i'm glad you said that because that's
what modern women do um actually one of
the number one indicators that a woman
is going to leave is she starts to outer
and her man and so and even when you're
talking about like education like or
they out educate their man like that's a
very similar story that i hear often so
you're actually kind of correct
women do that constantly and so when a
man when a man has the same standard
it's somehow like women get mad exactly
so if that is the case then we can't
complain about either side your provider
you do what the woman wants a lot of men
will say that it's entitlement well then
if you're at the money for your woman to
even have sex with you when even she's
not in them that's interesting
men don't mind providing for women that
deserve it well then a woman doesn't
mind opening her legs for man that
deserves it if you're if you act right
you'll get everything oh definitely so
why get into a relationship with someone
that don't deserve it then because you
don't always know who you're getting
okay now you you're waffling i don't
know sorry go ahead
hang away all right linda gone i just i
think there's maybe a discrepancy of the
definition of submission i think you
guys have a perception of what they mean
by submission and i may have a different
one so can we kind of clarify what we
think submissions yeah what do women
think submission is because it's
normally women that have a problem with
the word so what do you actually think
it is
um i think submission is understanding
somebody else's strengths so if you are
a man and you're telling me babe i need
to go and get this job and you're gonna
have to do this because this is the plan
and this is what you need to do i guess
i would submit in that in that position
because your planning is is what you do
best that's your skill that's what you
do if we're now in the house and you're
trying to tell me how is the best way
for us to spend money in the house when
i run the home then i'm not going to
submit to you trying to tell me that
because actually you need to respect my
role and i respect yours i believe
that's what submission is submission is
when you understand that in respect
somebody else's position being in that
situation specifically ahead of you do
you think do you think of yourself as a
submissive person listen i dated
nigerian for five years i know what
submission is and yes i am submissive
if if it makes sense i don't submit just
for the sake of things and when things
don't make sense i actually am able to
communicate clearly and maturely enough
to explain why this doesn't make sense
do you think you give off submissive
energy but that's not the point what and
this is the thing what i feel like is my
my strength and power as a woman is
actually a filter that i feel gets the
right people around me because when you
get to know me you understand that this
is what i'm doing as many of you know i
was just banned on tic tac and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible